an isis-inspired terrorist who'd already
attacked police once before
musa chowdhury remained determined to
kill
to launch further attacks to satisfy his
warped ideology now he's finally been
brought to justice
convicted of planning acts of terror
thanks to an undercover police operation
this was chowdhury in 2017 behind the
wheel of this car
as it swerved through bollards in front
of a police van
outside buckingham palace as officers
approached him
they had no idea chowdhury had a samurai
sword in the vehicle
he began punching out at them as they
tried to wrestle the weapon from him
he's screaming alaraka the whole time by
this point i'm actually in the passenger
side
of the vehicle so i'm struggling
quite violently with him for pcc and
midgley and gavin hutt
there is no doubt in their minds they
were involved in a fight for their lives
it was a an extremely sharp blade on it
and i'm you know amazed that myself and
ian didn't get
more more injuries than what we ended up
with to be honest
i wasn't going to relinquish the grip
that i had
but obviously when we started struggling
the whole implement came towards me
and embedded into the seed base at his
trial a jury believed chowdhury's
assertion that he hadn't intended to
injure anyone
that he simply wanted to commit suicide
to be shot dead by armed police
this despite his possession of extremist
material
and of a professed hatred for the queen
and the military
after his acquittal concerned that
chowdhury continued to pose a severe
risk
authorities kept a close eye on him
eventually launching a full-blown
operation
involving three undercover officers who
won his trust
as he bragged about his determination to
launch other attacks
musa chowdhury was an extremely
dangerous individual
he was absolutely committed to causing
harm to as many people as he could
i think the evidence we collected
through our covert officers
and which we put before the court
clearly demonstrated his murderous
intent
chowdhury discussed targeting a number
of busy london locations
including the gay pride parade madame
tussauds
and an open top tourist bus he bought
this replica glock pistol
and expressed his desire to get hold of
a real gun
he kept a knife under his bed and
practiced stabbing the side of his
canvas wardrobe
and he used these wooden swords to get
fit
and trained for a potential attack
although he denied this in court
and during an earlier police interview
it's nothing to do with an attack at all
okay um so uh you also obviously know
i've been in prison before
and i've been here before as well and um
a lot of my interests fall under all
these like weightlifting
martial arts training so anything you
want to ask i can answer it honestly
because there's no attack planning at
all although the jury at his previous
trial cleared him of launching a
terrorist attack
outside buckingham palace this time
around
chowdhury's claims of innocence were not
believed
the isis supporting former cab driver
is now a convicted terrorist mark white
sky news